[Music]
gusto is with us in Sacramento hey
Gaston how are you hi there I got a
question that I think it's gonna be
funny because you always talk about this
German polka master degrees and I'm
wondering if my son's career could fall
into that or not I think it doesn't but
I want to hear your opinion on that okay
he's going he's trying to pursue a
competition and doing film scoring and I
am a musician myself I mean I'm a pastor
but I am also decision and I kind of
supported him on this idea that go for
your dream and do whatever your passion
is and what you're good at but the thing
is he's gonna be going to be able to pay
the bills so if you have any thought on
that mm-hmm so he's getting a degree in
film scoring music what he wants to do
is a composition okay well I mean the
way you answer the question is not
asking me the way answer the question is
trying to figure out what the guy's
gonna do what's his job that's kind of a
question hi
was he already has he already gone and
done this no no he's a he's a senior in
high school this year
okay well my challenge to him is not you
know you can't just blindly say we're
gonna live our passion that doesn't work
yes I mean you could have a passion and
something stupid that no one will pay
you for and that's that's ridiculous you
don't want to do that especially going
spending money to get the degree in that
so I mean he is in California okay
Sacramento not LA but you know you're in
the vicinity of where a lot of film has
scores written for it
I'm not aware of necessarily people
coming out of college and immediately
writing music compositions for film
scores I would think it would take a few
years to build a reputation to build a
network of people that knew that you had
some talent even if you're talented and
so you're probably his first step out of
college is not to make a living writing
film scores that's my guess I don't know
I don't know that business that much but
I would guess that they don't hire a lot
of entry-level people to write film
scores coming out of college I can't
imagine that as a matter of fact but
it's possible but if he's a savant if
he's unbelievably talented like
world-class you know top 2% or something
maybe but the typical guy that's just
you know he's a songwriter coming out of
school I doubt it
about anyway so then what's he going to
do for a living yeah that's that's a
question right yeah and I don't know the
answer to that but he needs to answer
that question before he goes and gets
this degree okay because the the number
of people who make a living writing film
scores is very very small mm-hmm think
about it I mean it's very small and yeah
and my concern was because we we moved
to the space a couple years ago and we
we were not expecting to pay for for
college so we didn't do any funds we're
debt-free but but we'll have the ability
to pay for his education at this point
mm-hmm he needs to pick a school it's
very inexpensive and plan on working a
lot while he's there and then hopefully
you can throw some in to help him as he
goes but so so he's probably not going
to UCLA film school no yeah of course
but because of your videos he's been
working very hard on the SATs because
you know that will help him get some
scholarships and that's after so he's
kind of working and he's intentional
about it but at some point I think we
will have to make like big decisions on
that and and I'm not sure if a music
career is worth those big decisions or
you know I mean a music a music career
could be but you know what does the
music career look like I've got a friend
who plays in the local Orchestra and
make
a pretty good living doing that you know
and if that's what he wants to do that's
okay there's nothing wrong with that
there's not but but I want this young
man an assignment of his if I'm his dad
is you have to tell me before I'm going
to participate in this decision with you
how you're actually going to make a
living because I'm gonna just throw out
a number I'm just making this up I don't
know if it's accurate but let's say that
a thousand people which is probably the
most possible actually make a living on
the planet writing film scores for a
living it's a very narrow field and it
probably is going to take some time to
break into or an unusual level of talent
to break into or both and so as your be
plan where the music composition should
compensate a compensation composition
see I keep saying why are you asking me
anything you know if you've got that
degree as a B plan what are you going to
make a living so let's find a way to
live our dream in such a way that it
doesn't become a nightmare that's all
we're saying and that's loving him well
guide him and that's not the time I'm
not to do it but don't do it unless you
can tell me how you gonna make a living
of a van writing a film scores this is
the Dave Ramsey show